angry seas and dangerous swollen rivers
dennis is the second storm in a week to
batter parts of the UK blowing in
shortly after storm Chiara blew out
dennis has brought floods and
destruction to Wales and western England
in Herefordshire cars became flotsam
borne away by the waters because storm
Chiara had already saturated the land
Dennis's heavy rain swiftly turned roads
to torrential rivers from fields into
lakes the town center of 10 Barry wells
in Worcester [ __ ] was submerged it can
take months for people's lives to return
to normal after this kind of event it's
up to my thigh in the sitting room and
everything that we put up on boxes last
night is floating well we've got
electricity so were really lucky so
we've been serving philosoph tea and
coffee and hot water somebody wanted it
but you know I mean people are starting
to sort of evacuate now Prime Minister
Boris Johnson quick to visit storm hit
areas while campaigning for December's
election has yet to do the same this
time but the government has announced
plans for a new 1.5 billion dollar
supercomputer that will try to predict
weather and climate change faster than
ever before
bats won't stop storms like Denison
Chiara of course but more warning should
mean better preparation and that could
prevent future storms being so
destructive
Rory challon's al-jazeera